jerome powell was recently on a panel
and he was asked about inflation and the
health of the u.s economy and in it he
said we now understand more how much we
don't understand inflation now that
exact quote probably has your brain in a
blunder asking how the hell does the
central bank not understand that if they
print a bunch of money and they go ahead
and manipulate interest rates down that
inflation would take off well here's
exactly what jerome had to say
i think we now understand better how
little we understand
about it that's not very reassuring no
you know honestly this was this was
unpredicted at the time of our june
meeting one year ago
the of the 35
people who filed
with this survey of professional
forecasters 34 of them had inflation
below 4 for last year of course it was
way above four percent so really
everyone had the same model which was
the phillips curve model and it just was
not capable of producing high inflation
but what it was missing was something
that's completely missing in the data
for 40 years which is basically a
collapse of the supply side you know the
the us economy is famously adaptable you
know it does it has the minimum of
structural rigidities all that kind of
thing and yet here they are so you so
what you had was very strong demand but
hitting effectively a vertical supply
curve so ordinarily when people want to
buy cars which they really did because
they didn't want to ride on public
transportation rates were low they had
all these savings
the car companies would make more cars
and they might raise prices too in this
case
they couldn't make as many cars so so
what you got was straight up the
vertical supply curve a big price
increase but i also think in principle
at least that process could work in
reverse so that as demand comes down you
know inflation could actually come down
more quickly than would be then would
you know there are other relationships
that people think about when they think
about how do you get inflation down
which are more typical of a simply
overheated economy and an entrenched
inflation the sacrifice ratio and those
kinds of things but i think this could
be i don't know that it will be but it
could be different because it's just
that process working in reverse now it's
important to call out that of course
this is hard the u.s economy and the
global economy they're complex machines
to anticipate that any one person any
one central bank or any one group of
individuals could actually understand
all of the different levers the inputs
the outputs and what the impact of every
single decision could be is nearly
impossible i don't envy these people i
don't think that i could do any better
job but that ultimately ends up being
the argument is that should humans
actually be driving monetary policy
should humans be driving fiscal policy
especially when it is in response and it
is reactive to market conditions we got
intense loose monetary policy and also
immense fiscal policy stimulus when
there was a market downturn due to the
kovid 19 crisis
now all of a sudden back in november of
2021 when asset prices were running to
the sky
we got a federal reserve that stepped in
and decided that they wanted to crash
asset prices they wanted to destroy
demand and they simply wanted to try to
bring inflation down
many of these policy makers many of
these decision makers they simply are
using data that is backwards looking
all of that inflation data is telling
you what happened over the last 12
months but it isn't necessarily
effective or helpful to tell you what's
going to happen in the next 12 months to
come and so what we have are humans
using backwards looking data to make
decisions today that affect our future
this is a very hard problem and it's one
that frankly i don't think anyone can do
perfectly and so ultimately the question
becomes should we have an algorithm
something that doesn't change simply do
the job
if we can automate monetary policy
there's a lot of people especially in
the bitcoin community that believes that
it would be easier for individuals and
businesses to plan their financial
futures it's interesting to see jerome
powell the chairman of the federal
reserve start talking so openly and
honestly about some of the mistakes of
monetary and fiscal policy in the united
states
i tend to think that what we're seeing
now is its true thoughts and it's
encouraging that at least we're getting
a more raw look into the thought process
and the emotions of some of these
decision makers the chairman of federal
reserve and the treasury secretary they
aren't elected positions in fact they're
simply appointed and they have bosses
which are the politicians that appointed
them and so naturally when you have a
position where you don't answer to the
american people there's a lot of people
who ask the question
should they be elected officials i don't
necessarily think that's where we should
go
but i do think that journalists and the
american public should be asking much
tougher questions of these individuals
where did we go wrong
why did we go wrong and how can we
ensure that we have the ability to make
sure that we get back on track and that
we should be able to trust
that the united states can get inflation
down and that we can stop any sort of
spiral into a recession i don't have
those answers i have way more questions
than answers but i do know that now
we're starting to get a tone
from our policymakers from those people
in positions of power and influence it's
very different than what we heard in
2020 and most of 2021